erstmal entschuldigung für die komische
lichtqualität und das komische setting
und tonqualität und alles mögliche hab
ich das gerade mit meiner kleinen
blocking kamera in österreich urlaub im
hotel zimmer meiner eltern hoch war ja
erst mal möchte ich euch natürlich frohe
weihnachten wünschen dir heute am 24
ich hoffe ihr verbringt die zeit heute
schon mit freunden mit der familie und
ich hoffe dass es euch gut gehe die
selbst bereits im titel eingeblendet das
schlimmste jahr meines lebens und zwar
ist das für ein bisschen das worüber ich
heute im video reden möchte also das
geht hier heute kein detail glückliches
spaß unterhaltungs video sondern mehr so
ein bisschen labern und ja keine ahnung
2009 10 war halt sondern total abgefuckt
das ja irgendwie war 2009/10 viel
komischer als jahre davor irgendwie
wieder so schnell vorbei einfach war
seit sieben jahren in meiner familie
immer über weihnachten nach österreich
damit wir alle quasi so ein bisschen
zusammen kommen und diese zeit zusammen
verbringen weil ich wurde ja in köln
meine schwester und in berlin meine
eltern in bielefeld und das sogar
gemeinsame ort und letztes jahr habe ich
hier aus dem urlaub ein best-of
hochgeladen vom jahr 2018 aber dieses
jahr fühle ich mich irgendwie nicht so
danach und wollte einfach kurz ein
bisschen labern irgendwie war 2009 10
für einen hälfte extrem geil und zur
anderen hälfte extrem beschissen da bin
eine kleine liste vorbereitet mit dingen
die ich 2009/10 echt cool fand und die
ich halt erlebt habe und gemacht habe
deswegen würde ich die gerne einfach mal
so ein bisschen vortragen mit mir so
vorlesen als erstes habe ich jetzt auch
stehen dass ich das interview mit doppel
gemacht habe also mit dominik was so ein
bisschen für mich selbst auch outside
the box content war da war ich sehr
stolz drauf habe ich ein eigenes fifa
trikot rausgebracht in kooperation mit
vielfacher gemein sind allerdings auch
mega viele und auch mega coole korb
zustande gekommen wie beispielsweise mit
auto damit der ideenexpo 3000 leute von
euch nur wegen mir halt wirklich da
hingekommen sind dann beispielsweise mit
rainer schild mit google play dann die
drag-queen geschichte in münchen mit
prosieben dann beispielsweise setzen der
dreh mit julia und der bundespolizei als
auch kampagnen die nur möglich gemacht
wurden
durch meinen guten freund und manager ja
also auch an der stelle danke an dicht
dass wir quasi immer noch so in der
konstellation zusammenarbeiten damit
nicht auch sehr froh darüber hatte den
stärksten monat aller zeiten seit denen
youtube mache mit 51 millionen views nur
auf diesem kanal hier das war auch mega
mega krasse sache nicht unfassbar kresge
freundin war auch im meilenstein für
mich dann habe ich den podcast gestartet
dick und doof mit sandra der ja
mittlerweile dauerhaft in den top fünf
top 10
spotify podcast charts ist wo wir auch
mega mega dankbar für sind wir haben ein
bestseller award bekommen für di luca
pizza 2 und zudem auch noch diego
kapitza drei jetzt vor ein paar wochen
raus gebracht und ich habe eine wohnung
in hamburg gekauft wo ich auch in zwei
monaten jetzt hinziehen werde
das auch so ein bisschen sicherheit für
mich bedeutet einfach was die zukunft
angeht und allgemein muss sich
allerdings ganz klar sagen ich natürlich
am dankbarsten für euch dass ihr diesen
weg immer noch mehr bestreitet also
einerseits ist meine reichweiten die
dhakas gewachsen sind nicht nur auf
youtube hier sondern auch auf instagram
tik tok et cetera und allgemein auch das
leben supported by beispielsweise dem
merger es ja auch an meinem geburtstag
dieses jahr bei anderen am ersten sechs
im ersten zwölf noch im september kurz
das waren auf jeden fall so ein paar
punkte die mir direkt in den kopf
geschossen sind die 2009 10 für mich zu
einem unvergesslich positiven jahr
gemacht haben allerdings gibt es auch
einige punkte die mich dieses jahr
wirklich extrem ja fertig gemacht haben
und zwar war das einerseits dass ich
drei todesfälle in der familie hatte ich
habe zum glück noch nie so richtig ja so
was erleben müssen bisher in meinem
leben aber das dann innerhalb von ein
paar wochen direkt drei also meine
beiden opas und noch meine oma von der
wir es wirklich nie gedacht hätten dass
sie quasi von uns gehen das hätte also
das ist ja auch hätten wir alle nicht
mitgerechnet
dann habe ich mich oder am jun und ich
uns getrennt was jetzt auch noch gar
nicht so lange her ist weil wir einfach
gemerkt haben so für uns beide
weil sie nicht funktioniert gerade er
besser wenn wir befreundet sind und die
club geschichte
die vielleicht für außenstehende erstmal
total larifari wirkte dann allerdings 50
bis 60 nachrichten artikel zeitungen
dich komplett angehen und dein ganzes
leben in frage stellen und du
von allen seiten beleidigt wird sodann
muss ich das als auch ganz andächtig zu
sagen so da habe ich immer noch nicht so
richtig mit abgeschlossen
beziehungsweise mit mit bin ich noch
nicht so richtig mit klar gekommen so
egal
zu wem ich was sage egal ob öffentlich
ist oder nicht ich denke weiß ich nicht
das ist immer mal im kopf drin ob man
das irgendwann ist das jetzt gerade blöd
fühlt sich jemand versteht ja keine
ahnung
es waren halt voll viele dinge habt ihr
auch gemerkt so die positiven dinge war
habe ich viel länger drüber geredet und
war noch viel mehr als die negativen
aber trotzdem überwiegen halt irgendwie
die negativen für mich in diesem jahr
2019 weil die negativen punkte die ich
jetzt gerade aufgelistet habe das waren
halt nicht so sachen wie beispielsweise
euch vorhin mein handgelenk verstaucht
und dann mache ich kurz pause für ein
paar wochen und dann geht's wieder
sondern sind dinge die deinen kopf und
eine gefühle um emotionen und ein
selbstbewusstsein und alles einfach zu
boden werfen drauf rum treten und dich
so komplett zerstören irgendwie das ja
das waren also so die negativen dinge
ein content hat sich danach mitte des
jahres ein bisschen verändert ich habe
es zu beginn gesagt dieses jahr hatte
ich meinen stärksten monat auf youtube
klicks angeht ich hatte 51 millionen
views einmal mitte des jahres und danach
ging's los mit dem ja dann gab es halt
die schicksalsschläge in der familie und
die klubs sache und daraufhin habe ich
halt ja irgendwie meinen kopf nicht bis
jetzt nicht so richtig frei bekommen
also ich kann gar nicht mehr einfach so
sechs stunden vor dem pc sitzt und
einfach produktiv sein so ich muss
zwischendurch ihnen die pausen einlegen
und mich ablenkt mit irgendwas am
bellevue ich glaube jeder der sogar
schon mal hatte weiß wie das ist vor
allem jetzt wenn man sodann auch mit der
ganzen familie also im urlaub ist dann
merkt man auch das ist nicht nur selbst
betrifft sondern halt die komplette
familie ja keine ahnung ein content hat
sich dann auf jeden fall auch dadurch so
ein bisschen zu ändern das haben auch
viele von euch die mich schon seit
jahren schauen ob das auch mitbekommen
so ist ein erster sachen hochgeladen die
mal schnell eine reaktion oder mal
schnell ein paar fans rausgesucht oder
so oft ich dann reagiert habe und viele
dinge die ich mir einfach in den kopf
gesetzt habe ziele die ich mir
vorgenommen habe für
ist ja wie beispielsweise regelmäßige
live streams of which oder auf youtube
oder keine ahnung wo es auch egal oder
beispielsweise auch die musikproduktion
die hab ich dann gar nicht mehr
angegangen
die ziele bin ich nicht mehr angegangen
dieses jahr weil ich einfach nicht den
freiraum in meinem kopf der vater das
dann auch irgendwie mit reinzuquetschen
aber ich will euch jetzt hier auch nicht
mit meinen ganzen problemchen voll
labern und therapieren sowas ist
weihnachten das ist heiligabend und ich
hoffe ihr verbringt die zeit euch mit
eurer familie euren liebsten einfach
genießt einfach heute den tag
wie bereits gesagt ich möchte jetzt hier
gar nicht nur negative stimmung
verbreiten und keine ahnung was
allerdings hat für mich das jahr 2019
einfach gezeigt dass wenn da alles
perfekt ist kann es direkt vorbei sein
man kann so auf wolke sieben sein und
dann sagt und dann ist man quasi auf dem
boden wieder zurückgeholt auf die in der
realität also meine lieben freunde ich
hoffe dass ihr heute vielleicht mal ein
bisschen euch die zeit nehmen um so ein
bisschen über alles nachzudenken
vielleicht euch mal so ein bisschen kurz
sind oder wie man das auch immer sagt
und man so ein bisschen darüber
nachdenkt was ihr habt und das einfach
mal schätzen so da habe ich jetzt in
urlaub so ein bisschen auch für genutzt
bereits gesagt wer das jetzt hier heute
kein typisches luca macht schwachsinn
oder spaß unterhaltung ist keine ahnung
was video sondern einfach mein wort zum
jahr 2019 dem heer wirklicher
schlimmsten ja meines lebens mehr oder
weniger allerdings möchte ich an der
stelle auch noch mal sagen dass ich
extrem dankbar dafür bin dass ihr auch
jetzt in dieser sehr schwierigen zeit
für mich die letzten monate immer noch
an meiner seite seit und mich weiter
dass reporter dass es nicht
selbstverständlich und ich weiß dass
definitiv zu schätzen und ich hoffe dass
hier auch in nächster zeit noch weiter
mit mir sein werden ich habe irgendwie
schon viel zu viel gelabert kommt es mir
vor ich wollte das video eigentlich voll
kurz halten aber dann bin ich in
gedanken und geschweißt und keine ahnung
was videos auf jeden fall morgen hier
wieder auf einem kanal in einer bereits
vorproduzierten wer würde er challenge
das mit einem sehr sehr lustiges video
ansonsten wünsche euch frohe weihnachten
heute wunderschönen tag noch und ich
werde mir auf jeden fall
nach dem urlaub ein paar tage aufnehmen
also um silvester herum
vermutlich nichts hochladen er muss ich
ja noch mal spontan gucken wenn ich in
köln bin allerdings ein bisschen
gedanken machen ja für neue ideen
freiraum schaffen wir mal im kopf und
ich hoffe ich geht es gut und ich hoffe
ihr bleibt gesund schöne grüße an eure
familie auch wenn ich die meisten
wahrscheinlich mich kennen und euch
einen wunderschönen tag und ich hab gar
nicht gefallen das war hier das sofa ich
höre
[Musik]